Some questions in the practice
section and then later on in the topic
assessment will require Mathquill,
our equation editor.
Mathquill can be used to type
the less than or equal to sign and
the greater than or equal to sign.
Your keeper probably has regular
less than and greater than signs,
but not less than or equal to or
greater than or equal to signs.
To type these signs using Mathquill
type a backslash and then
le for less than or equal to,
and then a space, or
backslash ge for greater than or
equal to, followed by a space.
Backslash is not the same
thing as a forward slash.
This is your backslash key.
This is your forward slash key.
This is the one that you want to hit.
So to type a less than or equal to sign
you would hit backslash, L, E, space.
Try it.
Try also writing these inequalities.
Don't forget to hit
the space bar at the end.